twitter is unique twitter is different
than every other social network you
understand that right it's open and it's
a social network every other platform
has become a Content push platform by
design right Facebook used to be when
you go to somebody's page and be all the
comments there if you guys remember how
that used to be right and so that's a
social network that's a conversation
twitter has such advantages but they
keep wanting to appease to corporate
America because that's where the money
is and I respect that but i think they
shouldn't completely shut off what makes
them so special which in a guy like me
who put in the work then the fact that i
would have permission because of the
product to jump into every conversation
just if you know mostly don't know this
my narrative is in two thousand six and
seven i jumped into every I mean this is
where we could surmise is it and I've
said this before we even met some eyes
is probably the backbone product of my
success when it came out and it was
searched i sat in my office in my
apartment and I for ten hours a day
minimum so let's put this in the context
it's a lot of [ __ ] time search wine
Napa Pinot Grigio and jumped into every
single public tweet and replied and
provided value going to Napa this
weekend which a lot of the techie SF
people would say and I jump and be like
where are you going and of course early
days Twitter be like whoa you know who
think people can see they're just so
early right there like but they look at
my profile as a host of wine library TV
so it was a gateway drug to what I was
doing I'd like well I don't know Kate
bread and
whenever I'd like on that [ __ ] you need
to go here and here and then I call the
owners and like I providing value right
people be like going this restaurant
need to worry about ordering the wine I
jump in I go on the website and a
quarter this isn't the now like I was
providing value but Twitter gave me that
ramesh permission because the context of
that platform is its open and it's a
cocktail party and you can roll up and
be like hey overheard you talking about
the jets game I'm really [ __ ] pissed
too you can only do that in a cocktail
environment you can't do that if like
you're sitting at your desk working and
I tap you doing hey you know and so and
so that's what every other platform does
its push it so I think twitter's missing
option plus I don't think they're
educating people on the platform my I
made a SlideShare a little while ago
that talks about the fact that if you
start a tweet with the hat civil only
the people who follow both of you see it
the amount of people it's a at Gary B is
the [ __ ] because they're trying to tell
everybody I'll awesome and I'm missing
all my PR out of that this is me off
right and nobody knows that like they
don't explain their product enough to
the masses and so they defaulted into
thinking the 2007-8 crew we remember but
a lot I mean there's people here that
didn't know that if you start your tweet
with the @ symbol and say that Cornell
Tech has been a great experience only
the people that follow you and Cornell
Tech will actually see that tweet and
people do that all day long why in the
world have they not not into a place
where you start that and a little pop-up
comes up and they just explain it one
time and everybody would know and so
it's little product features that I
think they struggled on as well so